[Música]
la organización amnistía internacional
publicó un riguroso informe que examina
el estado de los Derechos Humanos en el
mundo la región de América Latina no
sale muy bien parada con varios
problemas en común para la mayoría de
los países como por ejemplo la pobreza
la inseguridad restricciones a las
manifestaciones o la libre expresión la
región tampoco queda bien parada en
cuanto al trato a las minorías y a
sectores vulnerables que ven como sus
derechos han sido limitados Día tras día
el informe también habla de ese doble
rasero que hay por parte de los países
de occidente para condenar a otros
estados por violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos pero no tiene el mismo estándar
para evaluar a países que son de su zona
de influencia y también destaca que el
2022 fue el año en el que toda la
atención mediática estuvo enfocada en la
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania que desvió
completamente la atención sobre otros
temas importantes de este lado del mundo
hoy en el debate de France 24 no
hablamos de Derechos Humanos la
hipocresía de América Latina pues para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Carolina Jiménez ella es presidenta de
la oficina en Washington de asuntos
latinoamericanos ella pues como lo digo
se encuentra en la ciudad de Washington
en la capital de Estados Unidos y desde
la Ciudad de México tenemos a Ana piquer
director adjunta de investigación para
las Américas de amnistía internacional
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de este debate ustedes pueden
dejar sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook en Instagram y nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f-24 y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo no olviden
también que todos los contenidos de este
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces con Carolina dándole
la bienvenida al programa Gracias por
estar con nosotros Carolina allí en la
ciudad de Washington en la capital de
Estados Unidos y comienzo como Punto de
partida sobre este informe que es
nuestro punto de análisis el día de hoy
su opinión un overview sobre lo que
significa este informe y los puntos más
destacados y cuáles puede usted Resaltar
bienvenida Muchas gracias Santiago Un
saludo para la audiencia definitivamente
es un informe que retrata muy bien el
panorama actual no de las Américas en
general con respecto a la situación de
Derechos Humanos no de la región y y tal
y como lo dice el informe seguimos
viendo retrocesos muy importantes tanto
en materia de derechos económicos
sociales y culturales porque tres años
después de la pandemia las economías de
estos países no se recuperan no a los
niveles pre pandémicos Y eso afecta
derechos fundamentales y básicos como la
seguridad alimentaria el acceso a la
salud etcétera Pero también en derechos
civiles y políticos este un retroceso
democrático no que vive América Latina
termina reflejándose También muy bien en
la en la represión no y en y en la
intolerancia hacia
la disidencia no que hay en diferentes
países con respecto a los gobiernos que
están en el poder entonces creo que
tristemente no no vemos un un panorama
muy alentador pero es la realidad que
tenemos en este momento y la realidad en
la que hay que seguir trabajando para
para cambiarla ahora le doy la
bienvenida a Ana en la ciudad de México
para que nos cuente su opinión también
sobre este Punto de partida su opinión
general de este informe y puntos a
destacar bienvenida
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación y
por la oportunidad de hablar más en
profundidad de esto
Bueno concordar un poco con el análisis
que dice Carolina en el sentido de que
estamos viendo una situación de
retroceso en prácticamente todas las
Américas Y quizá en el mundo en el
sentido de que estamos afrontando crisis
económicas que provienen primero de la
pandemia y luego de la guerra en Ucrania
que ha afectado a todo el mundo
económicamente estamos viendo crisis
asociadas al cambio climático que está
ya es algo inminente que está afectando
los derechos de las personas y lo que
estamos viendo por el contrario es
estados que en vez de abordar estas
necesidades inmediatas están reprimiendo
a quienes de una u otra forma están
oponiéndose a las medidas de los estados
están
siendo parte de la disidencia o están
defendiendo sus derechos y Y esa esa
tendencia represiva es algo que es
extremadamente preocupante en la región
y que lo estamos viendo prácticamente de
del norte a sur de en todas las Américas
Ana continuó con usted en Ciudad de
México y pongo sobre la mesa un primer
tema y es la pobreza en América Latina
la pobreza ha sido un problema
transversal para la mayoría de los
países poco o nada ha cambiado a lo
largo de los años no importa el viraje
político que den los países
la pobreza Sigue estando ahí aumenta o
se disminuye en algunos puntos en
algunos grados Pero sigue siendo un
problema que afecta fuertemente la
economía el desarrollo de los países el
desarrollo de las sociedades y consagrar
esos procesos sociales que muchos
gobiernos han prometido hacer sin
importar De qué parte del espectro
político sea porque la pobreza no avanza
independiente de la coyuntura en la que
estamos Porque esa reducción Y esa lucha
contra la pobreza no avanzan los países
latinoamericanos
hay varias explicaciones y de hecho
yendo un poquito más en específico
recientemente el año pasado en amnistía
internacional publicamos un informe en
que hicimos como zoom En qué significó
la pandemia en las Américas Y por qué
las Américas fue uno de los de las
regiones donde hubo mayor mortalidad por
la pandemia del Coby 19 Pese a que
muchos países Se tomaron todas las
medidas que recomendaba la OMS y apunta
precisamente a eso a la Pobreza implica
condiciones de base de más riesgo
implica acceso a las alumnas de más
deficitario y y que eso pasa por
decisiones de los gobiernos en términos
de inversión gasto público y sistema
Fiscales y y ahí hay un análisis que
todavía falta y que también se puede
hacer en clave de Derechos Humanos en
términos que de que los sistemas
Fiscales de los estados impactan
directamente en Cómo se puede proveer de
derechos a las personas a cómo se les da
el acceso a la salud el acceso a la
educación el acceso a ciertos servicios
básicos que son la implementación de
derechos humanos y que hoy por hoy hay
una cantidad muy grande de personas que
no pueden acceder a ello y eso
nuevamente es algo muy transversal hay
países que están de extrema gravedad
como Venezuela o como Haití pero En
definitiva estas desigualdades profundas
es algo que no se no se no ha perdido la
voluntad política para abordarlo en
práctica en un país de la región
Carolina su opinión sobre este tema
coincido 100% con lo con lo que dice Ana
no O sea la desigualdad se ha vuelto Esa
esa palabra con la que se viene
describiendo América Latina ya de forma
casi retórica no O sea América Latina es
el el continente más desigual del mundo
y a pesar de que ya hay muchísima
comprensión sobre qué Qué efecto tiene
la desigualdad sobre las personas este
los países de la región no han podido
abordarla yo recuerdo claramente que
cuando comenzó la pandemia no hubo como
una especie de de solidaridad colectiva
no de dentro de cada país y entre países
donde decía todos estamos juntos en esto
no todos estamos en la misma Tormenta en
el mar y claro cuando se vio el impacto
diferenciado que tenía la pandemia este
en sectores de personas con acceso a la
salud los primeros que tuvieron acceso a
las vacunas etcétera del resto lo que
terminamos diciendo bueno fue que sí
ciertamente estábamos en en el en la
misma Tormenta en el mar Pero Íbamos en
diferentes barcos no y y grupos este más
afectados por la pandemia fueron
justamente los grupos en situación de
mayor vulnerabilidad socioeconómica no
grupos que históricamente han estado
marginalizados en diferentes este
lugares de la región entonces creo que
hay que decir basta no no podemos
acostumbrarnos a y normalizar que la
desigualdad es una característica
intrínseca de latinoamérica porque este
es algo que puede y necesita ser
cambiado y es algo que juega en contra
del desarrollo de la región si uno mira
el panorama general y la coyuntura en la
que estamos Carolina Ana uno ve países
que están algunos con un poco más de
avances que otros dentro de un sistema
supuestamente democrático ese sistema
democrático establece una cantidad de
reglas y para poderse sostener en cierta
forma tiene que tener una economía muy
robusta que ve éxitos y que se mantenga
estable la economía latinoamericana en
este momento no está pasando por el
mejor momento pero incluso los mismos
gobiernos que
de turno o recientemente han cambiado
han saboteado ese sistema democrático
saltándose también ellos reglas para
permanecer en el poder o abusando del
Poder y eso también vulnera esas
garantías y esos derechos para los
ciudadanos que empiezan a exigir o a
reclamar precisamente por ese mismo
Sabotaje que hacen los gobiernos hay una
crisis del sistema democrático en
América Latina y una crisis
de la gobernabilidad que está vulnerando
los los derechos humanos de los
habitantes de América Latina también
entendiendo y ya con esto termino que
las democracias latinoamericanas son
democracias relativamente jóvenes son
países que tienen 40 a 50 años después
de haber pasado por procesos de
Dictadura o por guerras Carolina hago la
ronda la inversa comienzo con usted
Bueno yo creo que el retroceso
democrático de América Latina es es tan
claros como la desigualdad no Y si hay
algo que hemos aprendido en estos años
es que hay una correlación entre
democracia y disfrute o no de Derechos
Humanos no entonces Mientras más
retrocesos democráticos vemos en la
región probablemente mayor violaciones
derechos humanos de diferentes no tipos
de derechos vamos a ver yo no sé Yo no
no soy de las que está de acuerdo con
con aquellas ideas de que bueno los
latinoamericanos no quieren democracia
no yo creo Sencillamente que Porque
además si vemos a los jóvenes sobre
todas las jóvenes
protestando no exigiendo derechos a los
periodistas a los sensores Derechos
Humanos a la sociedad civil se nota que
hay un proceso de resistencia no este
contra el retroceso democrático Pero lo
que sí es cierto es que la democracia O
al menos la promesa que hubo en América
Latina de la Democracia falló no Y
muchísimas personas en países que
apostaron no a a una ola de democracia
después de como bien lo decía Santiago
de años de gobiernos dictatoriales en
diferentes países terminó sintiéndose
muy decepcionada justamente porque la
democracia no abordó no las raíces de la
desigualdad y no abordó la desigualdad
socioeconómica que insiste Entonces eso
dio lugar a que hubiese un terreno
fértil para la llegada de nuevos líderes
autoritarios que prometían ser distintos
y arreglar todo en un año no y creo que
pues mucha gente de satisfecha cayó no
en esa en esa en ese esa alusión que
crean los líderes autoritarios Y si uno
mira las cifras de acuerdo a este a este
informe pues prácticamente todos los
campos han aumentado la pobreza la
desigualdad el retroceso en los derechos
para las minorías para las mujeres
censura de medios que ya vamos a
analizar todos esos puntos Quiero
conocer la opinión de Ana sobre este
tema
de si hay una aparente crisis del
sistema democrático en general en
América Latina
Sí o sea partir concordando con el
análisis de Carolina nuevamente y Y
quizá agregar que tal parte de esa
crisis ha tenido que ver con ciertos
discursos de ellos contra nosotros esto
o lo otro de ciertas falsas dicotomías
que ponen en en riesgo el respetar los
derechos humanos en su conjunto un
ejemplo típico surge con crisis de
seguridad en que hay un argumento de que
tenemos que sacrificar ciertos derechos
humanos y ciertas libertades porque son
algo así como un mal necesario para
poder garantizar la seguridad y en con
esa justificación se termina validando
medidas que van son contradictorias con
un estado de derecho y cooptando poderes
o adoptando medidas represivas y y que
con esa justificación de es para
proteger la seguridad se termina de
alguna de una manera validando esas
medidas Y eso es tremendamente peligroso
porque En definitiva esa dualidad es
falsa esa es una falsa dicotomía en el
sentido de que sin derechos humanos para
todas las personas no hay seguridad
garantizada para nadie y Y eso es es
algo que que el discurso de esa falsa
dicotomía es algo que ha permeado muy
fuertemente en la región y que
complementa todo lo que mencionó también
Carolina en que también por lo mismo ha
generado estos procesos de resistencia
claro proceso de resistencia e
incrementando esa polarización entre la
sociedad y quien no esté del lado de de
quien sea que está en el poder está en
contra de no hay un grado de tolerancia
entendiendo que hay un espectro político
y que la gente puede tener una
perspectiva diferente comenzó a meterme
con algunos de los temas puntuales que
cita este informe comenzó hablando por
ejemplo de norte a sur hablando del tema
por poner algunos sobre la mesa la
censura de los medios en México ejercer
el periodismo en México se ha vuelto
completamente
difícil 13 periodistas han sido
asesinados y según este comité la
protección para los periodistas pues ha
disminuido
considerablemente el 2022 solamente
países como Ucrania que es un país que
está en una guerra abierta contra Rusia
tiene cifras que superan un poco a las
cifras mexicanas preocupa mucho este
tema lo hemos analizado aquí en el
debate de France 24 Pero lo que más
preocupa es la inacción del gobierno
mexicano que además se ha mostrado
abiertamente en contra de los medios de
comunicación y los ha señalado y los ha
criticado por desempeñar su labor
Carolina la impresión que queda este
este panorama en México
es gravísimo que en el país que tiene el
triste récord no de tener la mayor
cantidad de periodistas fuera de una
zona de conflicto desde el poder se
deslegitime su trabajo y se desacredite
la importancia que tiene la prensa libre
independiente en cualquier democracia
hemos hecho muchos llamados que desde el
megáfono presidencial no hasta también
este los comentarios y las declaraciones
de diversos altos funcionarios del
gobierno de México eh inicien no un
proceso de legitimación del trabajo
periodístico en la narrativa propia del
gobierno pero lamentablemente lo que
seguimos viendo es es un descrédito
constante el trabajo periodístico cuando
el trabajo periodístico revela casos de
corrupción de violaciones derechos
humanos de abusos de poder del gobierno
o cuando este no no repiten la línea o
las narrativas
del opinión sobre este tema de la
censura de medios y le añado otro
problema importante en México el caso de
los derechos para las mujeres México
registró
3.754 homicidios de mujeres en el año
947 fueron investigados Como
feminicidios aún así las mujeres
mexicanas siguen reclamando
derechos para ellas y garantías de
seguridad se sienten completamente
vulnerables en su cotidianidad en su día
a día en su vida diaria Bueno usted está
en México mejor que nadie lo puede lo
puede ver de primera mano el tema de las
mujeres en México su opinión
Sí primero sobre el periodista quería
complementar un elemento Y es que en
México existe un mecanismo de protección
a periodistas y Defensores de derechos
humanos y que ha habido periodistas
asesinados Aún estando bajo la
protección del mecanismo Y eso también
es altamente preocupante porque tiene
que ver con que la institucionalidad que
el propio país se ha dado para dar
protección a periodista no está
funcionando y necesita de reformas
importantes para asegurar que permita a
las personas periodistas continuar
ejerciendo su labor de manera segura
respecto del caso de los feminicidios
ese es un tema que al que le hemos dado
prioridad por muchos años ya porque
lamentablemente no hemos visto mejoras
ni cambios significativos y acá ha
habido situaciones graves de de
impunidad y de falta de voluntad para
investigar adecuadamente los estos
crímenes lo que y esta impunidad es lo
que también
colabora a que En definitiva se sigan
repitiendo
Entonces es efectivamente una enorme
preocupación de que desde amnistía
internacional seguimos
trabajando activamente en conjunto con
la sección local
precisamente porque no lamentablemente
es uno de los grandes de las grandes
violaciones derechos humanos continuas
que ocurren en el país y a las que no se
le ha dado una solución efectiva no hay
solución efectiva hay pocos avances allí
en México y otro otro listado en donde
México está también liderando junto con
Brasil son los Derechos Humanos para la
comunidad
lgbtiq las cifras también son bastante
complejas entre el primero de octubre
del 2021 y el 30 de septiembre del 2022
Brasil registró más homicidios que
ningún otro país en el mundo y le sigue
México Brasil registró 96 y México 56
Ana también las minorías nuevamente
cuando se había dado ciertos avances
destacados en la región de América
Latina para la comunidad LG bti vuelven
a mostrarse vulnerables en países bueno
en dos países muy grandes e importantes
y influyentes de la región Brasil y
México
Sí y de hecho
por una parte es sumamente preocupante
que esas números hayan aumentado lo lo
de Brasil es alarmante y y también habla
de cómo en situaciones de retroceso las
primeras personas afectadas normalmente
son personas de grupos históricamente
vulnerables de minorías de
de grupos que que no todo el mundo queda
afectado por igual en esos retrocesos y
y en ese sentido el la comunidad lgbtiq
más ha sido históricamente discriminada
y vulnerada en la región y y al haber
estos retrocesos inevitablemente también
se va hay una afectación a estas
comunidades entonces claro es muy
alarmante en realidad el verlo y y es
parte también del ver esos retrocesos y
de esos también esos discursos anti
derechos y discursos como conservadores
que apuntan nuevamente a la
estigmatización la criminalización y a
la patologización de la comunidad lgbtiq
más que nuevamente significan un
retroceso respecto de algunos logros que
se habían conseguido en ese sentido
Carolina con este panorama de estos
cuatro temas que hemos expuesto en estos
últimos minutos la comunidad lgbt y las
mujeres en México y la censura en México
panorama general Qué se puede hacer para
cambiar la situación que se puede
empezar a hacer ya hemos hablado de esa
falta de iniciativa por parte de muchos
gobiernos o falta de
ganas de hacer proyectos sociales que
vayan en pro de mejorar la situación
muchos gobiernos le apuestan más a
tratar de mantener a flote la economía y
estos temas sociales pasan a ser
secundarios en los programas de gobierno
bueno es justamente lo mencionaba Ana no
esto un país como México y no es el
único no tiene mecanismos de prevención
de violencia contra los periodistas
contra los defensores derechos humanos
ahora cuando uno ve cómo los recursos
que van esos mecanismos la manera en la
que actúas se da cuenta de que este
difícilmente pueden hacer su trabajo
entonces La pregunta es a dónde está
yendo a dónde está yéndolo el dinero
dónde están yendo las prioridades
presupuestarias de cada país y lo
seguimos viendo con mucha mucha alarma
no siguen yendo a
el caso mexicano por ejemplo sigue yendo
a profundizar la militarización del país
no siguen yendo a a construcciones de
megaproyectos que dañan el ambiente
siguen yendo a campañas electorales
Entonces si no si no hay no una
reconducción de los presupuestos y de
las inversiones públicas de los países
en en prevención de la violencia o en
lucha contra la impunidad no en el
acceso a la justicia una vez que pasan
los crímenes que vemos que pasan estos
países Lamentablemente se repite el
ciclo de violencia y el círculo de
persecución contra grupos de
pertenecientes a minorías contra
periodistas etcétera para reconducir
esos recursos no y comenzar a cambiar y
a darle la vuelta a esta realidad sin
duda alguna se necesita voluntad
política o sea si no hay voluntad
política desde el poder difícilmente se
pueda se puede haber un cambio creo que
también obviamente esa política nos toca
a nosotros empujarla no Y creo que eso
es algo que hacemos desde la sociedad
civil de diferentes países Aquí hay un
tema paradójico y es el caso que les va
a poner a continuación porque claramente
hay una amplia voluntad política por
parte del gobierno del Salvador para
hacer frente a la inseguridad la lucha
frontal contra las maras contra las
pandillas
65.000 personas han sido arrestadas
desde marzo del 2022 en el marco de una
de un estado de excepción que fue
impuesto por el gobierno por un mes ha
sido renovado a lo largo de 12 meses y
ya cumplido un año muchos de estas
personas detenidas
anunciado que no han tenido el debido
proceso ante las autoridades judiciales
para rendir cuentas sobre esos supuestos
esas supuestas acusaciones que les
imputan aquí va uno una voluntad del
gobierno pero una voluntad que también
empieza a rayar los límites de exceder
un poco la mano y la fuerza en cuanto a
la necesidad de dar resultados y la
popularidad que le está dando la la
ciudadanía por por las por los planes
que está desarrollando Pero hay muchas
críticas al gobierno del Salvador por
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos vemos
la otra cara de la moneda aquí hay como
una especie de exceso de voluntad
política Ana
sí El bueno el caso del Salvador Es uno
que venimos trabajando hace tiempo de
hecho hicimos una misión El Salvador
Poco después de que se declaró el estado
de emergencia y el Salvador es quizá uno
de los ejemplos más claros de lo que
mencionaba antes sobre esta falsa
dicotomía de de decir para poder
conseguir seguridad es necesario hacer
todo esto que estamos haciendo Y está
justificado Incluso si es que eso
significa tomar presos a personas
inocentes que no tienen un debido
proceso que están ahí Solamente porque
eran pobres y tenían tatuajes y eso ha
significado que hoy día El Salvador es
el país que tiene la mayor población
carcelaria en el mundo
y que
se están dando condiciones carcelarias
absolutamente inhumanas que se está
deshumanizando por completo a las
personas ahí ha habido denuncias de
torturas ha habido más de Cien muertes
en custodia y y todo eso no no puede
simplemente justificarse porque es
necesario para la seguridad y y ahí es
Quizá el mejor ejemplo de ese falso
dilema de que todo vale para conseguir
un objetivo cuando En definitiva se está
poniendo en riesgo los derechos de
persona que hoy día pueden estar
encarceladas sin ninguna motivo
simplemente porque vivían en un lugar
determinado o eran personas pobres o
Tenían un determinado tatuaje o alguna
vez a los vio acerca de alguien que
estaba asociado a Una Pandilla Ana
Carolina justamente ese tema del
Salvador lo estábamos analizando también
en este programa en el debate y yo le
preguntaba a uno de los invitados que
estaba conversando con nosotros sobre
ese tema quiero hacerles la misma
pregunta para conocer su opinión y es
porque la sociedad salvadoreña le
retribuye al presidente bukele con esta
alta popularidad aceptando estas estas
reglas del juego digámoslo así de estas
medidas de seguridad Que prácticamente
ya se volvió una política de estado a
cambio de esa seguridad A cambio de
a los Derechos Humanos la gente no
denuncia no hay críticas y todos ven
simplemente los buenos resultados de
poder salir a la calle
en tranquilidad que no es menos Es un
logro grande sobre todo en un país tan
violento pero pero los ciudadanos tienen
el deber también de cumplir con unas
labores Como por ejemplo denunciar estas
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
Carolina cómo entiende uno esa
transacción o ese intercambio acepto
esto a cambio de esto sin importar el
costo
yo creo que se entiende primero desde lo
que fue la realidad hasta hace poco y es
de una violencia delincuencial excesiva
que tenía alas y los ciudadanos en
estado de sitio O sea hay que reconocer
que por muchos años El Salvador no solo
Tuvo una en las altas de las tasas de
homicidio más altas del mundo sino que
también tasas de extorsión de violencia
sexual etcétera etcétera más altas no
Entonces teníamos una población cansada
de la violencia y hay que reconocer que
ese cansancio no a pesar de las promesas
de diferentes gobiernos que de que iba a
acabar con la violencia puede terminar
resultando en la aceptación de políticas
de seguridad de mano dura no que tienen
ganancias temporales y a corto tiempo no
como las que ha implementado el
presidente bukele ahora bien Yo creo que
todas las personas quieren un América
Latina libre de violencia y y todas las
y los salvadoreños quieren un Salvador
libre de violencia Ahora solo algunos
quieren
un Salvador menos democrático y allí
creo que es donde radica no este el tipo
de Liderazgo que ejercen allí bukele
creo que hay que comprender y
solidarizarse no con las miles de
víctimas de la violencia de la incursal
de las pandillas pero lamentablemente
eso no puede no llevarnos a aceptar
políticas de seguridad que en primer
lugar están basadas en violaciones de
Derechos Humanos pero en segundo lugar
no son sostenibles en el tiempo o sea
encarcelar al uno por ciento de tu país
en tres años no es algo sostenible en el
tiempo vulnera muchísima gente dentro de
Mega cárceles que Probablemente van a
terminar generando otros nuevas nuevas
redes de criminalidad no van a ser
sostenible en el tiempo entonces Habría
que ver qué qué tipo de discusión vamos
a estar teniendo sobre la política de
seguridad de bukele en en dos o tres
años Sí el panorama claramente va a irse
modificando
la situación para cerrar este este tema
y quiero también poner sobre la mesa el
caso de Nicaragua ya que estamos allá en
Centroamérica un país bastante
particular las medidas que ha adoptado
el gobierno allí en los últimos meses
3.144 organizaciones a las que se les
canceló la personalidad jurídica 12
universidades canceladas exilio forzado
para más de 222 personas 300 de ellas se
les fue revocada o despojada la
nacionalidad nicaragüense entre otros
tantos casos de censura de medios de
cierre de emisoras a nivel local
nacional a nivel de la capital la lista
de Nicaragua es el larga y continua Ana
el tema es muy particular allí porque
ustedes mencionan que estas son medidas
de corto plazo en el caso del Salvador y
de Nicaragua vemos que esto está
tratando de poner paños de agua tibia
sobre una problemática diferente en cada
uno de los casos Pero esto Cómo se puede
hacer sostenible para garantizar la
democracia y garantizar los derechos
humanos en estos dos casos tan
complicados
efectivamente son situaciones diferentes
en el caso de Nicaragua En definitiva lo
que está ocurriendo es una persecución
consistente a cualquier persona que
forme parte de lo que el gobierno
percibe como disidencia Y eso ha
significado de hace años personas
encarceladas injustamente
personas que han sido torturadas en la
cárcel personas que han tenido que salir
de Nicaragua ahora ahora además se
produjo este esta situación de exilio
forzado pero ya de mucho antes personas
de la disidencia habían tenido que huir
de Nicaragua porque estaban en peligro
dada la la posición de disidencia en la
que estaban la persecución a las ongs y
a las universidades y tanto así que ya
mecanismos internacionales han hablado
de que hay evidencia de que en Nicaragua
se están produciendo crímenes de derecho
internacional
entonces ahí ya estamos hablando de una
situación de absoluta represión por
todos los flancos a cualquier posible
disidencia al gobierno de Nicaragua y Y
eso Por supuesto ya estamos hablando de
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
consistentes por mucho tiempo en que
como digo se puede estar configurando
crímenes de lesa humanidad Carolina su
opinión
Bueno yo creo que Daniel Ortega y su
esposa no porque es como un Dúo en el
poder no Rosario Murillo representan
el autoritario es muy esteroides o sea
es difícil pensar en otro país de
América Latina que en cuestión de cinco
días
desnacionaliza no le roba la
nacionalidad Y borra no del registro
civil de de sus países a más de 300
personas que considera
disidentes no libera dos personas
detenidas arbitrariamente pero
inmediatamente las coloca en un avión y
las destierra no y llegaron aquí a
Washington no y y fue algo realmente
sorpresivo para todos los que estábamos
aquí recibimos esa noticia no de de un
día a otro que llegan 222 expresos
políticos a la ciudad sin sin sus
familiares sin saber a qué venían este
sin sin sin sin alojamiento etcétera no
O sea cuando un gobierno no
medidas tan arbitrarias como las que
toma el gobierno nicaragüense
con frecuencia creo que estamos
efectivamente como decía Ana no frente a
un escenario ya distinto no solo de
comisión de crisis de de crímenes de
lesa humanidad sino de ningún tipo de
posibilidad no que se respete el estado
de derecho no hay ningún tipo de
posibilidad Estos son algunos de los
casos que menciona este informe
obviamente también se habla de la crisis
migratoria de Venezuela de las
manifestaciones que ha habido en Perú en
los últimos meses que han dejado más de
60 personas fallecidas también la muerte
de
de líderes sociales en Colombia esa
inestabilidad que hay con grupos
guerrilleros Pero ya voy llegando a la
parte final del programa y quiero hacer
entonces preguntas un poco más globales
ven ustedes algún tipo de
característica en los diferentes
gobiernos de América Latina que estén
promoviendo no promoviendo porque estén
dando pie a que este tipo de violaciones
a los derechos humanos se estén dando y
que no haya ningún tipo de castigo por
ello no haya ningún tipo de denuncia por
ello porque simplemente se está
normalizando un tipo de funcionamiento o
una característica de los gobiernos de
América Latina que simplemente estamos
pasando por alto nosotros como sociedad
como lo de Carolina
Bueno creo que efectivamente como como
decía al inicio del programa El
retroceso democrático de América Latina
se no se ha se ha profundizado no y lo
vemos en los índices ya sea del cono Y
este freedom House no que que América
Latina viene ya desde hace varios años
viviendo un declive democrático
y ese declive democrático
ignora ideología políticas no o o
corrientes ideológicas específicas o sea
vemos líderes de derecha o de líderes de
izquierda líderes de centro este
Rompiendo las reglas básicas de la
convivencia democrática eh llegando al
poder a través de la de métodos
democráticos como el voto no pero luego
quedándose en el poder cambiando este
las normas
existentes entonces esa Esa esa ese
autoritarismo latinoamericano que se
diferencia del de los años setentas no
donde quieran autoritarismo que llegaban
al poder a través de golpes militares
que ha venido no que hoy en día este usa
las redes sociales que llega al poder a
través del voto no que en algunos casos
incluso disfrute popularidad como es el
caso de bukele en El Salvador tiene
otras herramientas para quedarse en el
poder y desde el poder no cambiar las
reglas de juego y por lo tanto
lamentablemente perpetuarse no mucho más
de la Democracia este se los permitiría
Ana teniendo en cuenta se escribe del
que ustedes han hablado ese declive la
democracia que vuelve y reiterar a
Carolina en su intervención Aquí hay un
punto que creo que es importante tratar
y es ese declive de la Democracia va
también ligado a un declive de presencia
de estado en muchos países que deja
terreno Por ejemplo en el caso de
Colombia caso de Ecuador o caso de
México esa falta de presencia de estado
da paso a los grupos ligados al
narcotráfico que llegan a ejercer una
función casi como otro estado Te
garantizan seguridad te garantizan algún
bienestar a cambio de trabajar para tipo
de grupos al margen de la ley y van
ejerciendo una suerte de estado dentro
del estado y y ahí se empieza a ver
también otros escenarios de retrocesos
de Derechos Humanos porque claramente
como no son el estado oficial pueden
hacer y manejar la situación y la región
de acuerdo a sus propias reglas no sería
puntual y básico para cambiar esta
situación garantizar la presencia del
estado en todos los rincones de cada uno
de los países de América Latina no es un
punto central que yo veo que tal vez en
el informe no está planteado
bueno el estado es el principal garante
de derechos y a través de y el estado
Ana
creo que perdemos la conexión con Ana en
este momento Entonces Bueno le traslado
la pregunta a Carolina mientras
resolvemos el tema técnico de la
conexión o ya tenemos a Ana me confirman
ya la tenemos Sí en adelante adelante sí
no decía que el estado es el principal
garante derecho los tres poderes del
Estado tienen una obligación de
garantizar los derechos humanos y y en
ese sentido
o en ese buen sentido es que el estado
tiene que estar presente para asegurar
esa garantía y en ese sentido el
abandonar determinados territorios es
parte de la preocupación el el que Hay
ciertos y que también es parte de muchas
de las cosas que hemos estado hablando
de las desigualdades que se van a veces
en términos de que Hay ciertos
territorios donde el estado está
presente llegando con servicios con
seguridad con cumpliendo de alguna
manera con sus obligaciones pero a veces
dentro del mismo país hay territorios
donde el estado no llega o cuando llega
es a reprimir protestas pero no
necesariamente a
derechos o a garantizar la seguridad de
la población de una manera que sea en sí
misma respetuosa de los Derechos Humanos
pues Ana Carolina nos falta muchísimo
tiempo para poder analizar en detalle
este informe Muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros hoy el
programa se nos fue volando hablando de
este tema y tratando de abarcar toda la
región pero les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros y haber aclarado
algunos puntos y haber analizado algunos
de los puntos de este informe Muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros a
ustedes Muchas gracias también por la
sintonía y el nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos haber estado con
nosotros el programa fue producido por
Giovanni agudelo y Laura garzón y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera sigan dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas sigan con
nosotros
[Música]